want to learn how to survive a tsunami
grenade blast or
even falling out of a plane well we have
a new channel called
how to survive check out the link at the
end of this video
[Music]
millions of years ago the megalodon
shark was one of the scariest creatures
to ever lurk in our seas
and even before that the mosasaurs
reigned supreme terrorizing every ocean
creature in sight
both these creatures were the apex
predators in their separate eras but
what would happen if they had lived
during the same time
and thought how would this battle play
out
which creature would have the most
advantages
and who would win
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the megalodon shark fought the
mosasaur
before we begin our main event let's
look at the tale of the tape
weighing in at 60 tons you have the
megalodon
this giant shark is 25 meters in length
and swims up to 17 meters per second
watch out for its bite as it has a force
of 278
000 kilopascals the
mosasaur is disadvantaged in almost
every aspect it's shorter by five meters
it's about one quarter of the
megalodon's weight and
it has only about half of the bite power
of the megalodon's mighty jaws
but will the mosasaur be able to make up
for it with its
increased maneuverability let's find out
[Music]
the megalodon begins by hunting for its
prey
since it never had any foes it will be
the initial aggressor in this battle
the megalodon's hunting style relies on
sneaking up beneath its prey and
quickly attacking the shark spots the
mosasaur near the top
of the water since that's where it
mostly hunts its prey
the mosasaur as a reptile also comes up
for air
every hour the megalodon approaches the
mosasaur but
as it begins to open its mouth the
mosasaur is able to dodge it
this is because unlike the megalodon the
mosasaur has defensive traits
although it was the apex predator in its
time
mosasaurs would also hunt each other
this means the mosasaur
knows how to fight and with that skill
it's just able to narrowly dodge the
megalodon's initial attack
right now the megalodon is confused
after all it never had to
win any sort of battle unlike the
mosasaur
this is a rude awakening for the shark
as the megalodon is confused
the mosasaur is able to sneak away
quickly
using its defensive traits the mosasaur
uses this time to find some cover
in hopes of getting the upper hand on
the megalodon
the mosasaur's forward-facing eyes make
it easy to spot the megalodon
this means the mosasaur has binocular
vision
like a bird as the mosasaur stays in
hiding
it waits for the megalodon to get close
enough
finally it strikes since the megalodon's
body is far too big for the mosasaur to
bite
the mosasaur attacks one of the
megalodon's fins
and despite the megalodon being such a
massive intimidating creature
the mosasaur is able to chew through it
quite easily
that's because the megalodon is made out
of soft tissue and cartilage
the only hard part of its body is its
teeth
as the mosasaur bites into the shark's
fin the mosasaur might expect the
megalodon to either retreat
or die but since the megalodon shark is
so massive
it won't give up just yet with the
mosasaur chopping on its fin
the megalodon knows where the reptile is
at this point
the mosasaur is trying to swim away and
it can swim as fast as it wants to but
despite being injured the megalodon is
faster and will be able to catch the
mosasaur
the megalodon opens its mouth and
quickly chomps down on the mosasaur and
oh the mosasaur is down for the count
one
two three and the new champion
of the seas is the megalodon
unfortunately the megalodon won't be
able to comment for a post-fight
interview
that's because this win wasn't without
consequences
the megalodon took quite a beating more
than it's ever experienced before
depending on how bad the bite is the
shark
may bleed out but if it manages to
survive
it will continue on being the one true
apex predator of the ocean
sure the megalodon managed to survive
this but
what can you survive well luckily
we have the answer with our new channel
called how to survive
there we'll teach you how to survive a
tsunami
falling out of an airplane and so much
more
and we promise we won't kill you
check it out in the link in the
[Music]
description